c'est vrai que le combat de ce monsieur
martin de gens qui le comprennent et il
y en a plus en plus mine de rien qui il
ya plus en plus de gens qui sont fans
on en voit de plus en plus actuellement
vous quel est votre combat et que vous
avez à dire à à se boucher qui est si
voilà tous les jours lui de faire son
métier mais c'est toujours la même chose
en fait dans ce débat il manque toujours
un acteur et c'est la victime mais c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui j'ai ramené ce
cochon qu'on alors nasa sont assorties
d'une poubelle d'un élevage normand est
pour pour l'imposer dans le débat parce
qu'il n'est jamais présent et raconter
son histoire et vous voyez il a il a
quelques semaines et ce qui la détruirai
va pas voir ça c'est extrêmement
intéressés c'est violent quand même
pourquoi ça vous gêne alors que c'est ce
que vous consommez tous les jours c'est
vrai que moi voilà là là ça me fend le
coeur que sur carnet ata tous ceux qui
sont la chaussée que c'est le but de la
démarche que les téléspectateurs ont
pensé comme moi mais c'est vrai que là
de voir ce petit se séparer de son coin
c'est bon c'est pour montrer vraiment la
réalité pour montrer la réalité de ce
qui se passe tous les jours ce cochon il
ya quelques semaines il a déjà subi une
ablation de la queue à vif une
castration à vif
à l'image des dents est donc là vous
voyez là si vous pouvez filmer il un
petit hématome
c'est dommage il a un hématome sur le
village en fait il a été claquée par son
éleveur c'est à dire qui il a très peu
parlé pattes il va éclater la tête sur
un mur ou un seul parce que il
il était peut être malade il se
développe est passé rapidement et du
coup il est considéré comme un comme un
déchet il n'aurait pas pu être
profitable à son élevage du coup on
attend la sortie de cette de cette les
poubelles d'élevage medac la question
que vous vous posez moi aussi c'est est
ce que vous comprenez ces gens qui vont
vandalisé des boucheries et qui vont
faire des actions est-ce que vous avez
déjà fait des actions vous des actions
j'en ai fait beaucoup mais avant de
ramener un cochon sur un plateau télé je
me doute bien que la messe jeudi en
vitrine les cochons vous non mes mains
mais monsieur en un minimum de respect
je veux dire vous allez du respect pour
l'animal ce que ça s'abîme sas et
enlacer qatar été insultés mais au
minimum
un succès c'est un animal que d'insulter
leur fusée je suis pas venu avec un
steak ou alors j'aurais pu être à bout
et je redis emmener un carré pelouse si
vous êtes team boucher pourquoi que si
vous avez à dire non à vincent jour je
respecte la démarche militante de bail
de monsieur aubry ce que je n'aime pas
monsieur aubry cette forme d'intolérance
qui l'a de la violence
honnêtement moi chacun fait ce qu'il
veut fait avancer la cause de manger
moins de viande parce qu'effectivement
je me savais que non mais ou alors ne
pas manger militer pour ça fait passer
des messages mais pas de violences pas
d'une tolérance mais on est là plus rien
ou et la violence est ce qu'elle est là
où est ce qui est sûr trois vitrines
fissurer là on parle de on parle de
cailloux contre un carnage on parle de
vitrines contre des vies on parle de 2
d'un jet de pierre contre elle décide on
en est là et je me suis opposé les
versants est ce que vous avez déjà mangé
de la viande version pendant 29 ans et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé j'avais jamais
cette non j'ai peut-être ouvert les yeux
sur sur la justice qui se passe et
lanvollon et que vous essayez de
l'invisibilité
donc j'ai ouvert les yeux sont jamais
peut-être 76 cette sensibilité à la base
et j'ai découvert et bach par un
documentaire qui est sur youtube qui
s'appelle terriens et là j'ai refait
cette connexion parce que c'est vraiment
ça va ça décline vraiment toutes les
catégories d'exploitation animal et j'ai
compris que voilà sur ce point je
voulais pu mettre un centime dans cette
industrie parce que c'est de s'impliquer
ce genre de choses bernard laporte vous
allez en parallèle ils n'ont pas
cohérent dans le monde alors on va
laisser d'abord valu ne pas juste les
sedoc parce que il a des petits sursauts
comme ça
[Rires]
gynecol certains la priorité au direct
et qui se réveille après il se rendort
[Applaudissements]
et parallèles ne sont pas corée corée
rangs mais le sentiment est bon je
comprends qu'on puisse trouver que qu'il
ya une forme de brutalité dans la façon
de tuer les animaux
ouais mais il ya des animaux qui sont
tués très proprement aussi d'accord
comment on fait mais la bouche est en
face de moi le boucher et le clocher ne
tue pas les animaux non mais bush et
celle de bush et en basque on a vu des
vidéos m'aidera dans des abattoirs et
c'est vrai qu'ils sont ce qu'ils sont
vraiment vraiment je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui des vidéos ou plusieurs fois
et même rémi gaillard on en parlait tout
à l'heure à amis les vidéos alors on me
dit qu'on a des vidéos mais j'ai pas
envie de voir ses vidéos au one et two
sides events et les vidéos abjecte et
des vidéos qui paye les gens devraient
être aux joies de la vie de vincent
rolland finances avec leur argent quand
même bien alors bien on a déjà tous vu
ces vidéos est en fait il faut savoir
une chose c'est que la filière de
manière générale industrielle artisanale
mas va va dans le sens du consommateur
c'est à dire qu'on a compris que le
consommateur veut manger sain peut
manger des animaux qui sont élevés dans
le respect ne se mange pas mais je peux
parler c'est peut-être là territoire on
remercie donc bien le dire c'est à dire
qu'en fait on peut faire des choses dans
le respect est correctement
c'est à dire que hr indien dans l'idée
en est pas mal mais mais non on peut
faire les choses bien je fais parler de
moi mais mes confrères artisans sont
pareils c'est à dire que moi je choisis
mon éleveurs je sais comment les bêtes
sont élevés et ce qu'elles nourrissent
comment voilà je connais c'est moi qui
choisis la bête et je choisis également
l'abattoir et des conditions d'abattage
je choisis tout ça je suis le maître de
la filière comme beaucoup de mes
confrères
alors faut le savoir à nîmes